this fire was caused by something like
this
what you're seeing here is the battery
from an e-bike or e-scooter exploding
and the recent fire in New York was far
from the first time one of these devices
also known as micro Mobility devices has
started a fire in the city this is close
to our 200th fire this year see as the
popularity of electric micro Mobility
devices has increased so too has the
number of fires and injuries they've
caused now lawmakers are trying to find
a way to stop these fires from happening
but approximately 880 000 e-bikes were
imported into the US in 2021 and the
majority of an estimated 65 000 New York
delivery workers rely on these devices
for a living so finding a solution
without penalizing them is tricky let me
explain
so days after an e-bike fire set Ablaze
the 20th story of a New York apartment
block injuring over 40 people New York
City Council hosted a hearing on
solutions to e-bike fires listening to
that hearing you get a sense of how
dangerous these fires can be and how
hard it is to find a quick fix now the
problem isn't limited to New York there
were some 70 e-bike and e-scooter fires
in London in 2021 and an estimated 10
000 in China between 2013 and 2018 but
because of New York's close living
quarters and how many of these devices
are in the city many folks are actually
looking to us on the FDNY in New York
City is really taking the lead on this
the New York fire department said that
batteries in these devices are
short-circuiting or getting too hot and
that's causing these fires they explode
pretty spectacular and ignite the device
itself and anything near it obviously
the risk is Amplified when these devices
are left to charge in people's homes
often overnight often right by the
entrance and for delivery workers the
problem is exacerbated by how many miles
they sink into their devices see
delivery Riders work on average over six
hours a day for six to seven days of the
week according to a survey of delivery
Riders they're really getting a beating
out there this is something that's being
used you know 16 hours a day on City
roads with potholes in you know in all
sorts of weather that's a lot of
charging discharging and potential
damage to the battery all of which can
lead to battery degradation and fires
things get even more dangerous when
Riders try frankensteining different
parts from incompatible e-bikes or using
degraded second-hand parts
do-it-yourselfers are not do doing
anyone a favor now it is possible to get
e-bikes that have been certified to be
safe there's a certification standard
called ul2849 which basically means the
bikes have been tested and are regularly
inspected but right now there are only
13 e-bike brands that have been listed
to this standard out of the hundreds of
Brands out there now just because any
bike doesn't have this standard doesn't
automatically make it dangerous the
standard only came out in 2020 and right
now there's no requirement to have it
the problem is without it it's kind of
hard for users to know whether their
ride is safe but just not certified or
genuinely really dangerous
so it was being proposed by lawmakers to
try and stop this from happening firstly
there's discussions about ensuring all
e-bikes and e-scooters hit some level of
safety standard whether that's on the
whole device or just on the battery
itself we do need the federal government
to step up that could involve Banning
the sale or import of uncertified
devices but there are concerns among
some that certification could lead to
more expensive bikes and that could
price some lower income delivery workers
out of a job one suggestion is to give
rebates to delivery workers when they
buy certified e-bikes but it's unclear
who would foot the bill for this between
the government delivery apps or
restaurants and who would qualify the
sale of second-hand Parts could also be
regulated but according to delivery
Rider groups it's often hard to tell
which parts are second hand and which
ones are brand new if I can put you two
batteries in front of you you will not
even be able to tell me but one solution
to stop e-bike fires from happening
inside people's homes could be to stop
charging them there and instead provide
public spaces for charging outside
New York they're starting to do just
that investing one million dollars into
creating hubs for delivery workers at
places like this old newsstand and
there's a place where they can charge
their e-bikes get rest get shelter it's
a game changer now it's unclear how many
of these hubs will be created but
investing in safe public charging
infrastructure outside of Residential
Properties could be the solution to stop
these fires from spreading further
thank you